we are joined now by Democratic senator
Tim Kaine of Virginia he is a member of
both the Armed Services and Foreign
Relations Committee senator Kaine was
Hillary Clinton's running mate in the
2016 presidential election senator good
morning thanks Nora want to talk about
Syria we have 2000 US troops there yep
in Syria the president sent a letter to
Congress yesterday saying he has the
constitutional authority to do this
because it's in the vital national
security and foreign policy interests of
the United States that he doesn't need
Congress's approval sure no the
president's wrong I think this is an
illegal military act it's one that I
would likely support if he brought it to
Congress but we have a president not a
king and the Constitution says it's
Congress that gets to declare war not
the president what the president can do
is defend the United States against
imminent attack but if it's a matter of
going on offense against a sovereign
nation of Syria he's got to come to
Congress especially since they've laid
out that they've known for months about
these chemical weapons attacks
all right so other than that asking for
Congress's approval though you've raised
kind of a larger question though is
where's the strategy right very
important a military action isn't an end
it's a means to an end so what's the
what's the goal here after rockefeller
our troops did a great job working with
coalition partners to battle Isis okay
so now we're still in Syria what's the
goal now is it to prevent Isis from
re-emerging is it's a topple Assad check
Iran check Russia help Israel help
Turkey help the Kurds what's the
strategy why are we there that's how you
know whether a military action makes
sense or not but what the administration
hasn't done is come and present to us
and you saw the president 10 days ago
said we're getting out of Syria and then
last Friday night we're dropping bombs
on Syria so we need to we need to have
that strategic discussion this question
of whether as Authority matters because
is he taking actions out of his Lane
President Obama acted in Libya and he
acted in Syria outside of the
authorization of force after the attacks
of 9/11 so this is kind of a
presidential standard it's not something
aberrant that President Trump is it is
true and I criticize President Obama I
mean we're friends but when he went into
Libya without a congressional vote House
Republicans criticized him and I did too
when he wanted to use missile strikes
against Syria for using chemical weapons
I said he needed to come to Congress and
he did come to Congress and then he
followed the the
rules on that one on the Foreign
Relations Committee we voted to allow
missile strikes it wasn't his argument
about Congress in that instance with
Syria that basically Congress is not up
to the test that nobody wants to be out
there making a claim and staking their
reputations on these actions and
therefore presidents gotta act and in
this case the strategy is look they used
chemical weapons jang-hyun punish
whether the Congress is up to the test
and change the Constitution I got a kid
in the military you know why does it
require vote of Congress it's a judgment
that if we're gonna make our young men
and women risk their lives kill or be
killed it ought to be based on a
Congressional vote that this is in the
national interest and if Congress is
afraid to have a vote how dare we order
people to go risk the lives and the
lives of their colleagues I mean that
that's why you have the vote the other
reason you have a debate and vote is
that's what educates the American public
about what the stakes are if the
president just one off can do this or
that
what's the stop the president from
saying I need to bomb Iran I need to
bomb North Korea if he thinks he can do
this without Congress then he he
believes he can do anything with no no I
mentioned the two thousand troops there
there was some confusion about how long
they will stay there over the weekend
French president Makran said that he was
able to convince the president Trump to
keep the troops there longer the White
House has been walking that back what
are your views on how long troops should
be well it's I think it really begins
with the strategic discussion what are
we trying to accomplish okay then we
will know what the right role for the
troops are you're right the president
said he'd be out then we heard over the
weekend that maybe we'll be out in four
to six months but then I've heard
administration officials walk that back
so I actually don't know what the answer
is but this is the month April and May
we're on the Armed Services Committee we
write the defense authorizing bill for
the year and there's gonna be ample
opportunity for pindy to depend the
administration down on this let me ask
you about James coming Hillary Clinton
said he shaved her how do we how are we
supposed to take his new revelations I I
I don't think I don't think Jim Comey
was trying to affect the outcome of the
election I think he made a real blunder
by by violating two rules that the FBI
had with respect to Hillary Clinton and
following the two rules with Donald
Trump the FBI had two rules don't talk
about a pending investigation don't put
controversial material right before the
public right before the election he did
that with respect to
Clinton he didn't do it with respect to
Trump but I think it was more about
protecting his own reputation than it
was about trying to affect the outcome
of the race Eddie had to speak out in
order to make sure that there was
integrity for her presidency why
wouldn't use that part of his job is
that the FBI director know it's not part
of his job but if he was going to do
that why wouldn't he have spoken out
about the Trump investigation which had
been ongoing in the FBI as well there
was there was a clear double standard
but but look I I believe he was not
trying to impact the outcome of the
election I think he was trying to
protect his own reputation do you think
it did impact the election look there
were a lot of things that did and I
suspect it had some impact but I walked
back into my Senate office five days
after I introduced Hillary here in New
York for her concession speech and when
I crossed the mantle into my office I
realized this job just got much more
important that was before the election
and so I'm focused on things like Syria
trying to rein in an executive that once
the wage war you know without Congress
that's what I'm focused on all right
senator Cain thanks so much for being
with us thanks much